there's more to sight than just being
able to see the crowd you can definitely
feel the atmosphere there's a vibe in
the air there's the energy in the air
there's a sound it's amazing to hear the
fans especially when we were on the
tunnel
I'm Jake Wilson I'm the long snapper of
the University of Southern California
Trojans
I'm completely blind I have no eyes I
went in to play football with the
mentality that I had nothing to lose
long timing is an art you definitely
have the mechanics but a lot of it just
feel feeling that ball come off your
fingertips in a spiral how hard you're
throwing it you know where you're
releasing it just kind of getting that
velocity and in that in the accuracy
lights unfair
football's unfair but at the same time
it's up to you of how far you want to
take yourself when I was eight months
old
I was diagnosed with a rare form of eye
cancer called retinal blastoma when the
doctors found my cancer it was
completely taken over my left eye so
they almost immediately removed my left
eye from there on you know just a cycle
of you know the cancer coming back they
would fight out with treatments doctors
finally said listen we've pretty much
exhausted all all treatment options the
safer option is just you know the
removal of the eye growing up in the
2000s where coach Carroll was so
dominant with USC it was hard not to be
a USC fan I always loved football I
continued to play fly football my eighth
grade year after losing my sight it was
not anything close tackle football as I
entered high school I decided enough to
play football for my freshman and
sophomore year it really was something
that I didn't think I could do but
eventually my left of the game really
overcame any doubts and I learned how to
be an asset
money I just love the camaraderie of
football I love being part of the team
love putting on you know just the pads
and the Jersey and stuff and being part
of the team what was enough just that to
get me to try
[Music]
you